Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, and it’s time
for our season 4 preview of Arya.
The last time we saw her she was getting some
revenge for the events of the Red Wedding.
So I wanted to talk a little about her role
on the show and where the character is headed
in season 4.
Like I’ve said in all my other previews,
I won’t be referencing too many specific
events but beware minor spoilers for seasons
1 through 3.
Arya is like everyone’s little sister on
the show and I’ve always thought that she
kind of represents lost innocence in a way
that Sansa doesn’t.
Even though Arya has always been very different
from what you would expect of a princess in
a fantasy story, she really has gotten darker
and darker since season 1.
I really think the turning point for her character
wasn’t the Red Wedding, it was Harrenhal.
Remember that was the first time she said
her death prayer on the show.
I think Jacken too kind of introduced her
to the idea that revenge was possible when
he started killing the people she named.
But If you’ve read the books then I think
you’ll be really surprised in season 4.
I think that there’s a trip everyone is
expecting her character to take that they
won’t end up doing on the show till season
5.
It’s this huge character arc for her character
and since they haven’t cast any of the necessary
roles yet I’m pretty sure we won’t see
it till after season 4.
What does that mean for her character in season
4 and what is she going to be doing.
If you remember, she is still near the twins
at the end of season 3.
So she’s pretty far north.
If you look at the map of westeros too you
see that she’s between the Iron Islands
and The Eyrie.
Think about the idea that during the last
couple of seasons and even in the books the
main characters sometimes cross paths or travel
really near each other without knowing it.
So does that mean that Arya is going to run
into more of the other characters and which
ones?
I don’t think she’ll see Gendry again
this season unless she goes to the wall.
But I’ll talk more about him in a separate
video.
She’s not going back to Kings Landing with
the Hound, but I do think she’ll continue
to travel with him for most of season 4.
Let me know where you think arya will be this
season.
Will she stay in the riverlands?
There are some pretty big events that happen
there at the end of book 3.
Do you think she’ll travel to the eyrie
or somewhere else?
One place I don’t think she’ll be going
is The Wall.
Since the Hound is looking to make money off
her safe return I think he’ll try to take
her to the eyrie but something will happen
and she’ll run away before the end of the
season.
But let me know what you think.
I’m expecting some more amazing unintentionally
funny moments from arya and the hound this
season.
Remember in one of my other season 4 previews
I talked about how they were like this awesome
comedy duo.
I wonder if they write those characters to
be
funny together or if the actors just perform
it that way.
Maisie Williams is actually one of the new
most popular actors on the show, not just
because her character is awesome, but because
she is like the queen of vines right now.
Here’s a couple of her vine videos.
Be sure to let me know which one is your favorite.
And if you’re not, be sure to follow her
on twitter so you can see all her new ones.
A lot of people requested I do a preview for
Dany, so that will be my next preview.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll post that on monday.
In the meantime keep telling me which characters
you want to talk about the most.
You can click here to watch my Jaime preview
and you can click here for my tyrion preview.
Thanks so much for watching, high fives!